in some respects Scientology created a
near perfect communist experiment in its
sea organization
what is it from everyone according to
their ability to each according to their
need or something like that
Scientology C organization is damn near
a perfect communist experiment
coming from someone who doesn't
necessarily know the perfect communist
experiment really is because I'm not
grew up in a cult Lex you can't use it
as an excuse It's a funny tagline to use
in my videos I like it but like it is
interesting that an organization that is
so hyper capitalist and so money hungry
and is known to be very wealthy at its
core is run by these group of seog
members that live a communist lifestyle
we're gonna jump around let's go what is
sea org what is C organization what is
this organization the C organization is
the most dedicated version the most
dedicated brand of scientologists so
there's three like echelons of
scientologists there's public who just
live normal lives in the real world and
they pay to do Scientology courses and
auditing then they're staff members who
also live in the Real Worlds
uh but work on two and a half year
contracts or five-year contracts at
their local Scientology organization and
then once they finish their contract
there their debt is paid or whatever and
then there's the sea org members these
are the guys who sign the billion year
contracts they don't have lives in the
outside world they don't own property
they live in Scientology provided
housing they eat Scientology they eat
scientology-run cafeterias is there an
actual contract that says a billion
years it's symbolic but yes okay like no
it's not a legally enforceable contract
they haven't succeeded in enforcing it
in any subsequent lifetimes yet marriage
contracts should be like that a billion
years because not until death sauce part
but a billion years it really makes it
very concrete of what you're signing up
for yeah those are the billion year guys
you hear a lot about the billion your
contract the billion year contract
that's the sea org and and uh all of
Scientology Management International
Management middle management Continental
Management and even some lower level
service orgs are one composed 100 of
cork members
you're not allowed to marry or date
someone who's not in the sea org uh
you're also not allowed to have children
with anybody outside yoga in general
you're not allowed to have children sea
York members are not allowed to have
children unless they leave the sea org
if you they're you're expected to uh
have an abortion and stay in the sea org
because it's the greatest good for
Scientology if you accidentally get
pregnant interesting because it
distracts from the focus of the work
yeah what about sexual relations only
one's married but that's why people get
married after like three days you're
like hey you you look you look all right
let's get married are you allowed to
have divorce yeah you get divorced a lot
in the sea org I've known people who get
married divorced three times by like by
the age of 25. oh wow because in this
year getting married is practically like
dating right also unless you're married
you're living in dorms with a bunch of
other people so in order to get your own
room you also have to get married so
there's many benefits oh wow okay so uh
you mentioned communism in which way
because there is there a hierarchy
inside sea org is there a redistribution
of uh influence position money power and
sexy org everyone in this New York makes
50 a week everybody except David
miscavige but right and and some uh some
posts might have a cash bonus incentive
structure but fundamentally their pay is
50 a week so so even the head of a big
Scientology organization
is getting 50 bucks a week
our celebrities also part of seaworg or
not usually so this is really the
management layer
so what's the idea behind fifty dollars
a week is that basically live a humble
life they don't have to give you
anything at all it's just Oh you mean
like what's the idea behind not paying
yeah basically not paying
everything you need is already being
provided for you you're not here for the
money
you're working all the time anyway it's
not like you don't have days off I mean
you're you're working all the time
there's there's not it's there's no
concept of the weekends there's no oh
thank God it's Friday Friday's just
another day and however the position the
tasks the jobs uh allocated within the
sea org what do you mean like like what
kind of tasks you're doing what kind of
stuff you're doing it's very similar to
just any other
um business as far as you can have your
Human Resources you can have your sales
you can have your accounting your
operations your quality control it's
just that in Scientology your operations
is delivering courses and auditing so
your operations and your quality control
were most of the activity occurs as far
as delivering Scientology
and then you've got your you'd call it
business development but that's just
bringing in new members right
so the the the the function of
scientology's organization is very
uh very comparable to a normal business
in the normal world